Goooood morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
It's Question Tuesday, the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters.
It's actually the previous Friday, but I'm
going on vacation, so if anything important
has happened in the intervening four days
that I'm not talking about it, it's because
I don't know!
Let's get to the questions.
Q: BEARD?!
A: Yeah, I'm kinda growing a beard.
I dunno, Sarah wants me to.
What do you think?
Q: Why do none of the main characters in your
books have siblings?
A: It's just my little way of letting Hank
know that in my narrative imagination, he
does not exist.
Q: Do you still have your Holden Caulfield
hat?
A: You mean my people-hunting hat?
Yes.
Q: Apples or oranges?
A: I don't know, I find it difficult to compare
them.
Q: In your book Looking for Alaska, was Alaska's
'blank' a 'blank' or a 'blank?'
A: I don't know.
Also, that's not really the question for me.
The question is whether we can live hopeful
and thoughtful lives in spite of ambiguity,
in spite of the fact that important questions
go unanswered.
Q: Hey when's the Paper Towns movie come out?
A:There's an important question I will not
leave unanswered, June fifth!
I just watched like ten minutes of the movie
that Jake Schreier showed me when I was in
Los Angeles and I'm so excited, Hank!
Q: Do you have any productivity tips?
A: Yeah.
So first, procrastinate for a while.
Longer... longer...
wait until you feel, like, that sour panic-adrenaline
in the back of your throat and then GO GO
GO GO GO GO GO!
That's a terrible productivity tip, but it's
the only one I have.
Q: How many licks does it take to get to the
center of a Tootsie pop?
A: Between 115 and 500 and yes, there are
studies about this.
Links in the dooblydoo.
Q: Favorite Art Assignment video?
A: Pretty fond of Christoph Niemann's emotional
furniture.
I also really enjoyed the highlights video
where I got to make some prints with Sarah.
Links in the dooblydoo.
Q: Favorite song by Taylor Swift?
A: Probably Blank Space, or as Henry calls
it, "Boys Love Torture!"
Q: Hey, are you writing a new book?
A: Yeah, I'm..
I'm trying to!
Q: But are you writing, really?
Are you writing it?
A: Yes!
Q: But ARE YOU WRITING A NEW BOOK?!
A: Uh, I'm just gonna level with you.
That's not helping!
Q: Do you have any advice for people who are
engaged to be married?
A: The main thing that I'd say is that if
you're doing it right, your marriage will
be a lot longer and more important than your
wedding, so don't stress out too much about
the wedding.
Q: Do you listen to rap music?
A: Yeah, actually Nat and Justice introduced
me to a lot of artists I didn't previously
know about while I was on the Paper Towns
set, including Earl Sweatshirt, who I like
a lot.
And then in turn I got to introduce all of
them to The Mountain Goats, so it was a good
trade.
Q: If Nerdfighteria became a sovereign nation,
what would our national bird be?
A: Great question!
I'm gonna say owls because they're renowned
for their wisdom, they have, like, superpower
hearing, and they can eat a mouse in a single
bite.
Plus, you know, Hedwig.
So yeah, I think our national bird would be
an owl, but I'm open to suggestions.
Q: Do you get stopped at the grocery a lot
more now that Hank is so famous?
A: So one time I was at a movie theater and
I went up to the concessions and the woman
working there was so excited and freaked out
and she couldn't say anything for a few seconds
and then finally she said, "Oh man, this is
so wild because I have a huge crush on your
brother!"
Oh man, you think it's hard for me, Hank,
imagine what it's like for Dave Green.
Q: Do you think all children should be vaccinated?
A: No!
Like, for instance, kids who are immunosuppressed
because of leukemia shouldn't get some vaccines.
And there are some vaccines that infants shouldn't
get.
That's precisely why- I mean, in addition
to one's own health and the many pleasures
of not getting measles- that the rest of us
should get vaccinated!
Q: Can you anagram 'nerdfighters?'
A: Yes, my favorite anagram for 'nerdfighters'
is 'deft herrings,' although I'm also quite
fond of 'frightens red.'
Q: Favorite dinosaur?
A: Quetzalcoatlus!
Q: Favorite apostle?
A: John.
Q: Current toothbrush color?
A: Green.
See what I did there?
And lastly Hank, a nerdfighter asks, "What
should I name my pet rat?"
A: As far as I can tell, there's really only
one choice: Master Splinter.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.